Miley Cyrus and Liam Hemsworth seen out  on a date for the first time in years  hi guys i'm lauren zima this seems to be  the proof we needed Miley Cyrus and Liam  Hemsworth together again the singer and  actor split in fall 2013 but in January  we noticed Miley was wearing her  engagement ring again she has yet to  address her relationship status with  Liam though and now we've got these  photos to pair out together in West  Hollywood on Friday they hit up celeb  hotspot gracias Madre a vegan restaurant  Liam even held the door open for Miley  as they left the two were also joined by  Liam's  brothers Luke and Chris Hemsworth and I  witnessed cells et Miley and Liam looked  quote happy and relaxed it's kind of  cool huh it's incredible  now we love the idea of Miley and Liam  back together again and it seems like  Liam's family is on board too but what  do you guys think let me know on twitter  i'm at lauren zima